and today I'm gonna be showing you how
to convert your sprinkler system into a
drip system sprinklers are really
inefficient ways of watering plants in
general what they do is that they spray
water up in the air and onto leaves of
plants where that water will then mostly
evaporate into the air and very little
of it will reach the roots of your
plants and so what we're gonna do today
is replace a sprinkler system with a
drip system and so I well you see what
you see behind me this is called drip
irrigation tubing and this tube has
these little black emitters in it every
12 inches and this tubing when I when we
finish hooking it up will drip water
right on to the soil right where the
plants roots are and will this is a very
efficient system compared to the
sprinkler it puts the water right where
the water is needed okay so the first
part of installing a drip system is
actually closing off all the sprinklers
on your system that sprinkler system
generally is divided into stations and
you can you can't mix sprinklers and
drip on the same station the reason is
is that sprinklers put out a lot of
water very quickly so a sprinkler head
you know might put out several gallons
of water in a minute whereas a drip
system puts out water really slowly so
if you have drip and a sprinkler on the
same system in the amount of time that
it takes for the drip system to put out
a gallon the sprinkler might suit the
sprinklers might have put out 10 gallons
and so you don't want that kind of
mismatch so the first thing that we're
gonna do is find all the sprinklers that
are in that one station the sprinkler
heads
and just go ahead and screw the
sprinkler head off and then replace it
with a cap and so you're gonna do that
to all of the sprinklers on that one
station and then move on to the next
step
the next step is to actually convert the
sprinkler head that's closest to your
garden beds into a system that will
allow us to move from the PVC piping
here to this kind of drip irrigation
tubing so for my system here what I have
is the half-inch pipe coming out of the
ground and that's attached to the
sprinkler head so I'm gonna remove the
sprinkler head then I'm gonna attach an
elbow and this is an elbow that has a
female side and a female side with
threading on both sides so that means
this is both of these sides can be
screwed onto here so I'm gonna screw
this on and then into there I'm gonna
screw on this adapter this adapter
allows me to hook up to my drip
irrigation tubing and the drip
irrigation tubing will just jam right on
to this fitting so I'm going to screw
this in here now
now depending on what's available at
your hardware store you might not find
these exact type of fittings but just
talk to someone over there and they'll
help you find the one that fits right on
to your system you might even want to
take one of these pipes with you to the
hardware store so you can find the exact
fittings that will work for your garden
once you have your adapter on your
sprinkler head the next step is going to
be to install the backbone tubing okay
so what this is this is tubing that has
no holes in it all it's going to do is
deliver the water from where we put that
sprinkler adapter on two of the places
where we want the water to actually come
out so this this is just a half-inch
it's called 1/2 inch blank irrigation
tubing and we're gonna connect that to
the starter fitting but before we do
that what we need to do is dig a trench
and see you see I've already dug a
trench starting from where my adapter
fitting is going close to all of my
garden beds because what I'm gonna do is
lay down the tubing in this trench and
then attach my tubing that has the
emitters to this tubing the important
thing when you're purchasing these drip
irrigation materials is to purchase all
materials from the same brand because
each brand has a slightly different
diameter of tubing and if you buy
different brands they won't all fit
together I know it's silly it's annoying
but just buy one brand and stick with it
and it'll save you a lot of headache
later all right so now I have my blank
tubing and I'm just gonna connect it to
this adapter that I already put on here
so all after you to connect it is just
push the tubing over the adapter and
kind of wiggle it back and forth and
once I hit the end I'm this is a snug
really tight fitting it's actually
really really hard to get these off so
this is watertight completely when
you're putting this
this type of tubing on it really helps
to have some gloves with a nice grip to
them because your thumbs and your hands
will get really tired if you don't have
good grip on your hands so now I'm just
going to roll out my tubing right down
my ditch all the way to the end
so now what I'm going to do is I'm going
to make a cut in my tubing and insert
this T adapter so when you go to the
irrigation supply store or the hardware
store you'll find adapters like these
for the tubing's you have a T adapter
you have an elbow adapter they also sell
a straight adapter for mending broken
tubing and so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to install this T adapter here
into this tubing and the way I'm going
to do that is very simple I'm just going
to take a pair of hand pruners or any
other you know sharp cutting tool and
just make a cut right here and then
insert this T into the tubing and again
I just push it in and then again on the
other side simply push it in and now I
have a tight fitting there once the T is
in then I'm going to connect some more
blank tubing into the other side of the
T and now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to make a cut here right where
about the soil is so that the pipe
reaches just above there and then I'm
going to insert in elbow into that pipe
into this pipe here
and then put another little piece of
pipe onto that elbow and now cut make
another little cut so that just my pipe
is reaching into the bed and now that I
have my little connection on I'm going
to use another tee and I'm going to use
one of the side connectors not the
center piece to connect into this tubing
and from here we're going to connect our
actual tubing with the emitters in it
all right and now I'm going to start to
connect my emitter tubing so you can see
the emitter tubing it looks almost just
like the blank tubing but every 12
inches you'll see one of these little
black sort ovals
so you can see one is here now we got
another one here we've got another one
here so they're spaced 12 inches apart
and the water will just drip drip drip
out of these emitters when you buy this
tubing it comes in different versions
there are somewhere that the emitters
are nine inches apart somewhere the
emitters are 12 inches apart somewhere
the emitters are 24 inches apart there's
also different water ratings for the
emitters so you could find tubing that
where each of these emitters is going to
admit half a gallon per hour or one
gallon per hour just choose one and
stick with it because that way you'll
have even water wherever you're using
this tubing so what I'm using again is
the 12 inch spacing and one gallon per
hour perimeter so to start now I'm gonna
take that T piece that I just put in and
I'm gonna put my emitter tubing into
here and it is a little difficult to put
these on
okay now I'm just going to unroll my
tubing down the length of my bed and
when you're unrolling the tubing you do
want to actually unroll it if you just
try to kind of pull it off this way
it'll get all twisted up and it's
difficult to put to roll out
so actually unroll it down the bed and
when you get to the end go ahead and
make the cut you want to leave a little
bit of excess just in case you want to
move you know make any adjustments so
I'm going to cut weight up to you that
way I got play so the next step is to
attach our next lines of tubing the
number of lines you attach to a bed is
going to depend on the width of your bed
so these beds are about three feet wide
so I'm gonna attach about three lines of
tubing so now what I'm going to do is I
took a about an eight inch piece of
blank tubing and I'm gonna attach it
here to this tee okay and now I'm going
to attach another tee right here so this
is going to be my I'm gonna attach three
lines of tubing this is going to be my
middle line now I'm going to attach
another eight-inch piece of tubing here
and then I'm going to put an elbow on
the end
so now I'm ready to attach my second and
third line of my emitter tubing onto
this what I'm gonna do when I'm
attaching my next lines of tubing is
that I'm gonna cut my tubing here so
that my emitters are not lined up the
emitters like I said before on this are
twelve inches apart and so what I want
to do is stagger them so that I get a
really even coverage over my bed so you
can see this emitter that I've already
this tubing that I've already attached
has an emitter here so what I'm gonna do
is cut this next tube so that the
emitters are halfway in between the
emitters on this existing line so I'm
gonna make a cut just about here so I'm
going to cut off this end and now when I
attach this second line of tubing my
emitters will be staggered so you can
see I rolled up that second line of
tubing now I'm going to attach my third
line of tubing to measure where I'm
going to start on this tubing I'm just
going to line up with my emitters with
the first line because since I staggered
on the second line the third line should
be set should be cut the same way as the
first line so I just line up my emitter
and then I make a cut and now attach the
third line in to this last elbow here
and now I'm just gonna roll out this
third line and the front part of this
bed is done so now that I have my
connection all together here in the
front of the bed the next thing I'm
going to do is just pin my tubing in
place so I know exactly where it's gonna
go and so what I'm using are these
u-shaped they're called ground staples
and what you do is just take that staple
and put it around the tube and into the
ground and it should hold the pipe in
place so I just got a handful of them
here I'm gonna go along the bed and just
pin the tubing so that is nice and
evenly spaced apart all the way down the
bed and it's in the position that I want
it to be in
so here at the end of the bed what I'm
gonna do is I'm just gonna use one t
adapter to close all of these tubes off
and so what we're doing is we're
creating a loop between all the tubes
now there's no start point and there's
no end point they all just come together
and that means we're gonna have even
pressure throughout the tubing and the
water will get distributed very easily
so what I'm going to do now is I'm just
gonna cut the end of this tube off the
center tube and I'm going to attach this
tee piece here so just make sure we're
at the end of the bed and that looks
about right so I'm gonna make my cut
here and push this on
once that centerpiece is connected I'm
gonna connect just one of my other tubes
to that piece the reason being is I'm
going to leave one tube unconnected
because before I close this whole thing
off what I want to do is flush the
tubing out so before I actually connect
everything together I'm gonna leave one
tube empty on unconnected on every bed
turn the water on and let all the any
dust or dirt that might be inside these
tubes get flushed out that way they're
not there to clog the emitters when I
turn it on so just gonna make this cut
here and close this one off so now what
I've done is I repeated that same
process that I did on this first vent
here lunch my second and third bed I
took a branch off of our mainline I
connected it up to the top of the bed
and laid out three lines of tubing going
down the meds spaced them out with my
staples and then connected only two of
those tubes at the end and left one off
once your tubing is all together you
need to install your filter and the
place that you want to install your
filter is right where your valve is so
if you had a sprinkler system there's
probably some place in your house house
where you have a bunch of these valves
next to each other under some kind of
box and what I'm going to show you now
I'm just gonna demonstrate on this free
this loose valve how to install the
filter so what you'll need is a pipe
cutter and using the pipe cutter
whatever is coming out of this end of
the valve so that's the end that doesn't
have the black attachment pieces to it
you would cut that pipe off which the
pipe cutter and then unscrew whatever is
connected here okay and you won't need
that anymore what you then do is take
your filter and your filter will have an
arrow on it that with the direction
of the flow of water so the direction of
the flow of water is going to be down
from this piece that doesn't have the
black connectors connected to it and all
you're gonna do is screw in your filter
here and now that your filter is in
you're going to use a piece like this
this is a 3/4 inch female-to-female PVC
connection it doesn't have threading on
one side so it's just smooth on one side
on the inside and it has threading on
the other side so what I can do with
this is I it on to this filter and then
on the other side you'll connect back to
the PVC pipe that you cut before so for
example you have a PVC pipe like this
you're going to use this Christy's red
hot blue glue and what you're going to
do is with it with this glue you're
gonna apply a little bit around the end
of your PVC pipe and then you're gonna
apply another amount here on the inside
of this PVC pipe and just glue those
together ok and now all the water that
comes through here gets filtered by this
filter to empty these filters out
usually they just come out with a screw
and cap like this and so when you open
that up you can kind of dust a push push
out whatever's been filtered out and
also if you need to probably every few
years you open this whole thing up and
you can you can replace the actual
filter piece inside of here
ok so once you have that then your your
water is going to be doesn't it's not
going to have any particles in it that
will block up your tubes the other piece
that you might need that I don't have to
show you is a pressure regulator so when
you buy your drip tubing
on the tubing there'll be a rating for
how much pressure that tubing can handle
so maybe this to me you know maybe the
tubing says it can handle up to a
hundred psi of pressure well if my
pressure at my home is only 50 psi then
I don't need a pressure regulator to
keep this tubing in good shape but if my
pressure in my home is say a 120 psi
which it might be in certain areas then
you'll need to attach a pressure
regulator after the Y filter to bring
the the pressure down so that it doesn't
burst the tubing okay but in most cases
all you'll need is the filter as long as
you're using this half-inch thick walled
drip emitter tubing so now that
everything is set up the last step was
to turn the water on and flush these
pipes down so I've done that you can see
the water is coming out here it's also
coming out here and we're going to let
this run for a minute or so so that all
the water is coming is all the piping is
getting flushed out and after I let this
watch out for a minute we're going to
turn the water off and make this final
connection and then my drip system will
be done so now I've got my water my
tubes all connected together and I've
turned the water on and you can see here
the water is dripping out nicely out of
all the different all the emitters and
we have good coverage over the entire
bed and so now we can start planting
thanks for watching this video I hope
this gets you started setting up a drip
irrigation system at your own home and
if you have any questions feel free to
leave them in the comments and we'll try
to answer them as best as we can and if
you want to keep seeing our videos
subscribe to our YouTube channel Thanks
hi thanks for watching this video my
name is Rishi Kumar and I'm a member of
the growing Club the growing club is a
group of individuals and small
businesses in Los Angeles working
together to create a more equitable and
sustainable future every month the
growing club works to educate our
members our local community and our
global community on how to grow food
sustainably regenerate our urban and
suburban ecosystems and create
supportive and strong communities every
month we offer educational community
events here in Los Angeles and produce
free online learning materials available
to anyone if you enjoyed this video and
want to see more please consider joining
the growing club your monthly
contribution will help create more
videos like this one available to anyone
worldwide for free to join head to the
growing club comm and see how you can
become part of our growing community